من رام الله ينضم الينا مراسل صباح
العربيه الجميل خالد القاسم خالد يصبح
يسعد صباحك فطورنا اليوم فطائر معاك اهلا
بك انا بدك تعرفني اولا كيف جزائريه ما
عندنا الفطائر كثير شو الفرق بينهم
فطائر سبانخ فطائر جبنه فطائر زيت وزعتر
بس احنا غالبا يعني هناك اسمين معجنات
لمختلف انواع المعجنات ولكن همم زيت
والزعتر تسمى مناقيش في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه انا بديش افتي معي حبيبي ادريس
همم صاحب همم المخبز اللي احنا
على بابه طبعا من الرائحه الواحد بصيرحل
الله رحم نادين هنا راحت على العلا اليوم
الصبح حبيب قبل كل شيء بدي اسالك
احنا او الناس شو بتحب تاكل الصبح بكير
واي نوع معجنات بتختار يعني
اكثر شيء طلب ناس مناقيش زعتر زيت زعتر
سبانه جبنه بيضاء جبنه مع بيضه هاي فتره
الصبح اكثر طلبات الصبح
الظهر
فتره المغرب طبعا
[موسيقى]
مكانك مكانك مع جبنه كل شيء له شكله بس
عشان انت يعني تكون
حافظ جواها
شكل المعجن ولا طعمها واللي بيحكيس هويه
الفرن اه طبعا اكيد
همم
يعني ما بعكس ولا شيء بس طعم الكلام
طيب غالبا يعني اكثر شيء بنباعك طول
النهار مش الصبح او الظهر او كذا اقبال
الناس
جبنه بيضه جبنا زعتر اخضر يعني هذا اكثر
طلب الناس اكثر شيء بتطلب الناس باكل
اشياء عادي يعني اللحمه مثلا او المسحب
اول لك يعني هو موجود في الدار بس تبانخ
جبنه بيضه جبنا
مع زعتر اخضر هاي مطلوب اكثر شيء مطلوبه
يعني سهام فش مجال نفطر هون لانه همم
المحل شويه صغيره احنا هذا الشارع همم بس
ما اكد لك انه الرائحه تقتحمم في المره
اينما كانوا رائحه
المعجنات اكثر من 30 سنه صنف معجنات ويكون
موجود
بالفرن ما بعرف اذا ضايل معنا وقت سهام
ولا خلصنا
والله انت شهيت عادل قبلي يا خالد
انه ما راح ياخذ معه وهو رايح طالع بره
المعمل انه ياكل هذا الاكل هذا مش من
عوايدك يا خالد لا مش راح اصبر اخذ مش
اصبر اخذهن معايا انا راح افطرهم هم
جاهزين بس المجال جوا ده يعني
شكرا
حبيب القلب